si comme moi vous détestez faire le
ménage justement profiter de la rentrée
pour venir vous équiper et justement
j'ai un super bon plan dreamir présenté
à l'IFA qui a le gros salon de la
rentrée des nouveaux produits dont
notamment en aspirateur robot le Dream
Lee L20 ultra et lui il va vachement
vous aider pour venir nettoyer votre
maison en profondeur au-delà d'un
portail nettoyage intelligent pour tout
votre maison grâce à la techno mob
externe il va bien nettoyer les plaintes
et les recoins difficiles d'accès et
compagnie ça c'est vachement cool quand
il arrivera sur un tapis ou sur une
moquette il va venir relever la
serpillière on va pas bien nettoyer un
tapis de moquette de la même manière
qu'on viendrait nettoyer un parquet ou
un carrelage par exemple il est en plus
de ça une énorme puissance d'aspiration
de 7000 Pascal il y a un entretien une
maintenance automatique du robot va
venir scanner votre maison il a de
l'intelligence artificielle il se
recharge hyper rapidement vous pilotez
tout ça grâce à une application bref
c'est un must have à la maison pour la
rentrée en robot aspirateur on s'est
vraiment allé voir ce qui se passe du
côté de chez Dream League c'est le Dream
League L20 ultra une petite bombe restez
là parce qu'on en parle très bientôt sur
ma chaîne youtube et vous allez voir
franchement ça envoie du